abone ol
ilk
[Alkış]
öncelikle Herkese merhaba işinizde beni
tanıyan larımız var mı el kaldırabilir
misiniz lütfen
Aslında tahmin ettiğinden daha çok iş
var tanımayanlar için kendimi tanıtayım
Ben de çık 11 sınıftayım ancak 11.
sınıfta oldum genel olarak tahmin
edilemiyor birazcık kısa olduğundan
milyon olduğundan Tabi olabilir kutu
Bu konuyla ilgili ve bir anlam bahsetmek
istiyorum Geçen cuma günü bildiğiniz
üzere tabak Sen önce yani Shell'de her
yıl yapılan bir festival var o
festivalde İki Arkadaş İki Arkadaş
edindim ve Bu arkadaşlar daha önce beni
bokul hiç görmediklerini söylediler
ama
inanın o kadar tanımıyorum ve bilmiyorum
Peki ben şu anda niye buradayım Ben uzun
zamandır kendini ifade edemediğini
düşünüyorum ve Bugün buradayım çünkü
size kendimi ifade etmek istiyorum Size
bir Farkındalık yaratmak istiyorum ve
Aslında en önemlisi de kendi korkularını
üzerine gitmek istiyorum ve Bugün bunun
içinde
Peki korkuların üzerine gitmek istiyoruz
demişti bu korkuların neler
şöyle açıklayayım Öncelikle Hata
yapmaktan gerçekten çok korkuyorum tuz
ve bu hataları yaptığımda beni eleştirme
nizden ve Daha sonrasında Ben
eleştirildiği için kendimi eksik ve
yetersiz etmekten çok korkuyorum ve
bunun sonucunda toplumdan dışlanmaktan
vekab
Evet hem de çok korkuyorum Siz de böyle
korkularınız var mı
var biliyorum ama ben bunları çok daha
fazla da yok mu şekilde yaşıyorum şu
Zeki şu anda nasıl hissediyorum Şu anda
kumar alanından çıktığım için inanılmaz
sesle Hissediyorum Çok heyecanlıyım ve
çok Tedirginim
Gerçekten şu anda başım dönüyor ve de
inanılmaz derecede buradan koşup açmak
istiyorum ama dediğim gibi korkularının
üzerine gideceğim Bu
ekip o kadar yoğun hissettiğim
Duygulardan bahsettim
bunların bir adı var aslında bu kadar
yoğun hissettiğinde buna sosyal Fobi
deniyor bu ve bunu sosyal Tabii ben de
bazı şeyler yaratıyor mesela Yapmak
istediklerimi yapamıyorum çünkü
deneyecek gücü kendimde bulamıyorum ve
hiç denemeyi tercih ediyorum Hata
yapmaktan korktuğum için hiç denememek
bana daha kolay geliyor
ve hiç denemeyin CD hayatını
yaşayamıyorum Aslında ve Kendimi
inanılmaz güçlü hissediyorum böyle kendi
ve iletişim konusunda da kendimi güçlü
hissettiğim için kendimi
konuş konuşamadığım için
iletişim konusunda da çok sıkıntı
yaşıyorum insanlarla özellikle
arkadaşlık ilişkilerinde sıkıntı
yaşıyorum sanki önünde bir duvar var ve
o duygusal duvarı yıkamıyorum gibi
geliyor hiç kimsenin umrunda değilmişim
gibi geliyor
ve bu durumda da içe kapanıyorum ve
yazdı yok Yalnız aştığında da aslında
konuşabildiğini bildiğim için kuru
potansiyele sahip olduğunu bildiğim için
de kendime çok öfkeleniyorum
Peki bu anlattığım sosyal Fobi neden
kaynaklanıyor
Öncelikle kişisel özelliklerini
yaptığından bahsedebiliriz ben çok dışa
dönük bir insan değilim ve ayrıca kendi
kendime vakit geçirmeyi de gerçekten
seviyorum
sakin bir insanım ve bu aslında
ben kendi kendime vakit geçirirken
sıkılmama satın alma sağlıyor Bu yüzden
evde kalmayı da seviyorum aslında ama
evde kaldıkça sosyal fobinin arttığını
düşünüyorum ve daha çok yalnızlaşıyorum
ikinci neden olarak Away tutumlarından
bahsedebiliriz buraya biraz sonra daha
çok değineceğim ne oluyor o yüzden bir
saniye ki neden olan diğer çevre
faktörlerinden bahsetmek istiyorum bunu
da şöyle örnek verebiliriz mesela
biliyorsunuz ki size yaşadığınız
Karantina döneminde çok zor bir dönemden
geçtik ve herkes evlere kapandı Az önce
bebeğin tutumlarından bahsettim ve bu
evrenin tutumlarını size anlatmak
istiyorum
örneklendirmek içinde sürekli eleştirmek
ı yaslanma ve aşırı tepkiler verdi gibi
Söyleyebilirim
ama burada en çok değinmek istediğim
konu koşullu sevgi konusu çünkü bu
gerçekten ülkemizde çok yaygın olan bir
durum ve bir çocuğa
yapılabilecek çok kötü bir şey şöyle
örnek vereyim
bu mesela bir çocuğun Sınavda başarılı
olmasını istiyorlar Aslında ebeveynleri
Ailesi çok iyi niyetle ancak başarılı
olmadığında ya da onların istediği gibi
bir insan olmadığı için onların istediği
gibi davranmadığı için onu Ailesi ilgi
ve sevgiden mahrum bırakıyor ve bu
çocukta Özgüven eksikliğine sebep oluyor
bu da çok önemli bir kolay
Evet şimdi özellikle değinmek istediğim
bir şey var burada doğum güzel olduğunu
hiç gibi yetişkinler kitabından aldım
Bunu onu da burada almak istiyorum
İki tane kavramından bahsedeceğim
aslında da birincisi İlk çocuk ve
ikincisi iç anne baba bu üç çocuğumuz
Aslında bizim özelliğiniz yani bize
kimse yargılanmayacak olsa hiç kimsenin
ne düşündüğüne bakmadan ne yapardınız
İşte bu o benliğimiz onu yapan doğal ben
neyim
ve herkesin içinde bulunan bir de iç
Anne baba var bu iken ve babada daha çok
eleştiren ve acımasız vermektir
ve bu verdikte daha çok ebeveyn
tutumları ve çevreden etkilenerek
Başkaları ne der Başkaları ne düşünür
benim hakkımda
Ben bunu su önemseyen verdiğimiz dir
ve burada Aslında değinmek istediğim şey
bu aslında iki sesin içimizdeki iki
sesini çocuk iç anne babanın sosyalpopi
de o içeride babanın daha baskın olması
daha baskın olduğundan dolayı özümüzü
dışarı yansıt anıyoruz
bu peki bu konu hakkında ne yapılabilir
ve bu konu hakkında bunu Aslında ben
hala yapmaya çalışıyorum hepsini
yaptığım söylenemez ama sadece Size bazı
önerilerim var Bu konuda da hala Hata
yapmaktan çok korkuyorum ama korkuya
rağmen buradayım ve deniyorum
denemekten korka bilirsiniz ama nefes
alın ve yapmak istediğinizi yapmak için
bir adım atma içinizdeki gücü Fark edin
çünkü ben inanıyorum Herkesin içinde ya
zayıf ya da kuvvetli bir güç var ve bu
gücü dışlı dışarı çıkartmak sizin
elinizde aslında
Ama dediğim gibi hata yapabilirsiniz
keşfe sıkıntı yok Herkesin hata yapma
hakkı var ve mükemmel olamazsınız Bende
şu anda buraya kadar bir sürü hata
yaptım ve ve şu anda hala yapmaya devam
ediyorum hatta sözlerini unuttum
kısımlarda oldu siz bunu fark
ettiğinizde fark etmeseniz de
ve ayrıca başkalarının düşünceleri sizin
gerçek değiliz olmasın çünkü
başkalarının düşünceleri başkalarının
düşünceleri onlar Orada kalsın bırakın
Bırakın istediklerini düşürsünler Deli
Desinler manyak resmen hiç fark etmez
Siz siz olun
ve bu anlattığım şeylerden bir şey daha
değinmek istiyorum duygularımızı
bastırmayın Çünkü Duygularınızı
bastırdığımız zaman onlar içinde sıkışıp
şu atak verebiliyor Ben bunu yaşamış
biri olarak size şunu tavsiye edebilirim
Duygularınızı bastırmak yerine ifade
edemiyorsanız bile bir kağıda yazmak
olabilir mi şarkı söylemek olabilir Bir
resim çizmek olabilir Bir şekilde onu
anlatın ve İçinizde bırakmayın onu bu ve
en önemli noktalardan birine geliyorum
ama başkaları için değil Kendiniz için
yaşayın yani kendinizi
gerçekleştirir yapmak istediğinizde
odaklanın
başkalarına değil
[Alkış]
ederim Şimdi de Bu kız çok şey yapmamızı
Anlattı anlattı ama herhangi bir kırılma
noktasına bağlanamadı diyebiliyor içine
olur işini olabilirsiniz konuşamadı bile
rehber konuşamıyorum yani düşünün O
kadar size diye birazdan bayılacak yani
burada
bu aslında
bir adam bir krema noktasına
bağlayacağım Ben şu anda çok korkuyorum
ama buradayım Ve kendim için bir adım
attım ve Konfor alanından çıktım
Şu korkuya rağmen harekete geçti ve şu
anda bu dakikalarda şahit olduğunuz bu
dakikalarda benim kırılma noktasında da
ve bu krema haftasında böyle birlikte
olduğum için çok mutluyum
[Alkış]
Bu da benim Beş yaşındaki fotoğrafımı
büyük ihtimalle annemle Saklambaç
oynarken falan anne fotoğrafını çekmiş
şu anda özellikle Karantina
dönemindeyken Evet bu çekmecenin
içindeydin Ama şu anda dışarı çıktım ve
buradayız peki bu saklandığı yerden
çıktım size çıkabilecek misiniz
[Alkış]
[Müzik]